No, risk. No reward we have to fight
My name is rave Katchadorian and welcome to my crazy life
Shut it down boys
Please tell me you didn't stay up all night drawing again. I know it's [hard] to start a new school
There's a whole world out there. There's a whole big world in there, too
This is my sister, Georgia.  Mom!  She's doing it again. She's Gonna get me arrested
Hello, not getting any younger here
Do that again and you're not getting any older either
This is my mom's new boyfriend Carl
Phone lady search for ways to get rid of kids. You don't like
Calling Mommy
Stop stop here
[I'm] breaking up
Go go
And this (Excuse me) is my new principal dwight
everything you have on is breaking rule number 22
What's rul number 22
Code of conduct read it look what's happening to your shirt?
Nobody needs to see where your chest hairs are going to be so yeah this year's Gonna be fun
No loitering moment people intense huh seriously, it's like. I'm in prison
No outside food no talking no laughing no going to the bathroom. [it's] pretty common rule. Don't you see rape my school
[I] found over the notebook
Rule number 26 [rated] out [loud] Written material deemed inappropriate will be destroyed bring the yellow bucket [you]
Don't understand these drawings mean everything to me creativity [has] no place in this school
Yeah, rules are rules [your] new principal
No, risk no reward we have to fight. We've got to take on the establishment
[all] right guys. I've given you all [your] assignments
Let's break every rule in the code of conduct to expose principal dwight. All right Katchadorian. [I'm] in let's do this
What are you doing? Just excited to get to school early really?
Oh my gosh
That could have been me if you get caught you're gonna end up in a new school called prison
I will find the hooligans, and I will bring them to justice, but the megaphone is on the fritz sir
all right, like my big but
It's good day
Whoever did this is committed to the art
you